Hocus Pocus is so full of magic it was
hard to fit it all in we'll be getting
into all the deleted scenes that weren't
completely lost on 1993's Cutting Room
floor as well as some special moments
from Hocus Pocus 2. number one they
reshot the entire ending months after
they wrapped after finishing up filming
in January of 2022 two test screenings
showed that audiences found the ending
to be weak so they rushed to reshoot it
in June of 2022. the filming was shot in
Providence Lincoln and Newport Rhode
Island but the reshoot took place in
Astoria Queens
cannot steal their souls without him
number two a gem that didn't make it to
the Final Cut Is
but was given a nod in the sequel we
loved the moment in Hocus Pocus 2 when
the Sanderson sisters are scouring the
beauty section of Walgreens in the
original Hocus Pocus script there was
actually a scene where they take a trip
to the grocery store to buy ingredients
for cursed candy crows but unfortunately
it didn't end up making the cut the only
footage we can see of it is in an early
trailer from 1993. no time
number three did Mary leave The Cauldron
on this scene was just a quick bit of
Comedy as the residents of Old Salem are
about to execute the Sanderson sisters
did I leave the call before I don't know
would you mind just running in and
checking the cards clearly she does mind
how
incredible number four just a bit of
Teen Angst stepping onto the screen the
blobs are fat mouth about my personal
stuff and I'm supposed to take her
trick-or-treating forget it Dad it was
clear even without the scene in the
original film that Max was not a fan of
Halloween and definitely not a fan of
taking Dany out trick-or-treating not
this year Danny his dad isn't hearing it
though and hits him back with a
sarcastic jab about his driver's permit
I guess you're probably not big enough
to get your driver's permit this year
now we get a bit of a backstory on how
Max ended up trick-or-treating with
Danny unfair totally unfair life is give
and take Max it isn't always Fair number
five something we've never really heard
Salem Massachusetts described as before
look at this place it's a paradise come
on
so we've given him a paradise this
deleted scene was basically just Max and
Danny's parents talking about how glad
they were to move their kids away from
Los Angeles California and into the
paradise of Salem Massachusetts no
earthquakes no smog yeah no mudslides
that's right there is a fun moment of
foreshadowing though the only thing we
have to worry about here is
which is
La might not be looking so bad after
being face to face with the Sanderson
sisters which is
which is it's fun number six Sarah
Jessica Parker is giving major
flirtation in this deleted scene ladies
ladies this is a magic bus but I do need
a token or it's uh Winifred said Sarah
this looks like a job for you Financial
equivalent poor favor as she pushes her
sister towards the bus driver perhaps
you would care for a small token of My
Affection we're not totally sure what
happens next but perhaps Disney deemed
it too spicy for a children's movie
number seven the moral of the story is
never take candy from witches in the
original shooting script there was a
storyline where the witches would use
candy crows to possess and lure children
to their home this was supposed to be
the reason why Emily ran through the
woods and made her way to the Sanderson
sisters but it did inevitably get cut
out Elijah Elijah has to see my sister
Emily
look number eight R.I.P to Winnie's
makeup here this is one of the few
scenes that didn't get completely lost I
spent a lot of time just trying to
figure out what she was going to look
like based on our extensive Hocus Pocus
research this is a scene where Winnie is
trying to admire her reflection in the
pool I thought because she was so very
vain she had serious makeup
unfortunately though Winnie ends up
accidentally falling into the pool
neither Sarah nor Mary want to take the
blame so they each point at each other
saying she did it in a classic Sanderson
sister way when Winnie gets out of the
pool she lets out a good natured laugh
right before shocking Mary and Sarah
with a jolt of electricity they smolder
as Winnie becomes completely dry number
nine more Teen Angst cut from the film
what about you Max what are you supposed
to be
a rap singer in the original shooting
script there was supposed to be a
montage of an annoying Max explaining
his Halloween costume at all the
different houses I'm a blind center
fielder I'm Christian Slater I'm Jack
Nicholson's long-lost zombie son I'm Ray
Charles I'm her brother number 10. the
painting we never got a chance to see
another scene that was cut from the
original shooting script was when Max
Danny and Allison are exploring the
Sanderson sisters home on what Max would
consider his and Alison's first date
Danny this is the girl in my dreams
while exploring the house so take her to
the movies like a normal person Jenny
Allison being the resident Salem expert
points out a painting of the Sanderson
sisters to Max and Danny explaining what
they were like that's Winifred the
eldest her father was a warlock this is
Mary her father was a bloodhound and she
could follow the scent of a child for
Miles Sarah the youngest was strange she
would lure children usually young boys
in into the woods to play and they'd
never be seen again number 11 the 90s
when Disney would make being a virgin a
plot Point remember when Max lights the
black flame and that basically causes
the entire plot to unfold instead of all
the light bulbs around them exploding
and everything going dark there was
going to be a sort of black hole instead
all of the lights in the room were going
to be sucked into the black hole of the
candle followed by a howling wind and
then of course the laughter of the
Sanderson sisters who've been
resurrected number 12. who else's
favorite character is the cat version of
Thackery Banks well you'll be
disappointed to find out so for three
centuries I got to the house on All
Hallows night there was almost an entire
sequence that would have shown
flashbacks of his life as a cursed cat
when I knew some Airhead virgin might
light that candle number 13. this is
another one for the Binks fans in the
film once the Sanderson sisters are gone
binks's soul is set free but in the
original script the ending was totally
different different banks turns into a
regular cat who can't talk anymore then
the movie closes with Alison and Max
sharing a kiss along with a few more
lines of dialogue right before they head
back home what do you think of that let
us know in the comments number 14. we
would never complain about more Billy on
the screen in this scene we would get to
see Max Danny and Allison traveling
through these underground tunnels at the
same time as Billy who is actually
looking for them in the Final Cut of the
movie The only evidence we see of this
search is when Billy loses his fingers
after getting run over number 15 the
storyboards were a bit different than
what was captured on screen Sarah was
supposed to have her nose clawed at by
Binks who definitely does not identify
as a nice kitty when he was going to
throw a fireball at the car's tire and
Allison was supposed to be in the
driver's seat though we do get a nice
call back to the deleted scene about the
driver's permit wow let me see a driver
so what do you think of all those
deleted and extended scenes delicious
which ones do you think should have been
left in in a sacred place oh sacred
place we are not allowed in though let
us know what you think in the comments